herder da bei der arbeit
adrian notz hat eine mission er will der
künstlerin und designerin sophie
taeuber-arp ein denkmal setzen und zwar
ein großes auf dem bürkliplatz mitten in
zürich
du hast du mit selina die erste prozent
vor dem turm woche machen wenn man alle
48 millionen 15
conny
der direktor sieht die 36 meter hohe
skulptur ganz plastisch vor sich sie
würde wie ein hochhaus in den himmel
ragen
da könnte die meinung der
stadtpräsidentin nicht ganz unwichtig
sein
corinne mauch ist ein erklärter fan aber
solch einen turm will sie auf keinen
fall in ihrer stadt haben
mütze wenn man jetzt zum beispiel kommt
sage okay das ist kultur ticket sich 150
notrufe aber sie können sie ausbrachen
und sofitel
notes findet die titel der hübsch aber
zu wenig radikal
sie kennt sich aus mit
aufsehenerregenden christa de carouge zu
gast im cabaret voltaire als designerin
schuf sie kleider die selbst wie
skulpturen wirken
geht es nach ihr wird aus dem bald
wertlosen geldscheinen eine tapete
das meer ist gesicht wirkt sie schlägt
eine kombination von turm und tapete vor
mit einem ziel der tun da ihm der
hutmacher wo die lytro in trance hand
das alles auswirken und karriere
doch eine letzte station auf der
rettungsmission für die diakonie
stippvisite bei künstler kerim seiler
gerade plant er eine bewohnbare
riesenskulptur in johannesburg er weiß
also die kleinen aber zentralen details
wenn es um das monumentale baum geht
was ich nicht ganz sicher bin ich jetzt
ihre thermen berlin mit der inzwischen
als ad hoc pflicht unsere mehr
abschließen
aber ob die tour mit viel viel höher
werden würden ihm 150 extrem schön hobby
was uns ruhig ganz 69 der user sollen
orten so dass ein besseres erinnern sie
hat die schöne grüne so viel darüber
erfahren will mit seinem gedankenspiel
regt adriano zum träumen an
er baut sophie teuber arbeit denkmal
indem er der realität ein schnippchen
schlägt
ganz im sinne von dada